what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
a fresh and fit clip titled single mom
asks fresh or asks why fresh avoids
single moms before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily
videos while you're at it guys go follow
my instagram the link is in the
description
it's just probably things but instead of
an s at the end it's a z
[Music]
so i actually recorded a clip of you
guys especially with you fresh
when you were saying that um you were
talking about your ex-wife saying that
she was the perfect
woman she cooked
everything but the child was in the way
so i want you to go
more in depth because i i don't
understand because
you made it seem like okay single mom
doesn't have
any chance at all are you a single mom
yes
okay so give it to her bro all right
break it down for her
yeah um so the raw uncut version is
so she's a great girl obviously you know
cut clean
did everything cool the problem was that
like i
at that age was like 23 right oh you
were young um
i didn't understand fully what it meant
to be accept that
okay and my mom was like hey do you know
where you get into is it
the right thing to do as a christian so
i did it right um and
when i got into that situation it was
like yo
i have to be a dad and i was ready to be
a dad
also as well like picture this if
i'm coming to america to be successful
for me personally like
anything that's not gonna help me on
that path is gonna hold me back so
unfortunately
me even providing for the whole family
itself and then
having to like not grind on my on my
business after work
take him to the park it was holding me
back and
i came to america to become successful
so that's why i said uh the kid was cool
not bad kid at all uh hopefully he's
doing well today but
i just knew that i couldn't be the one
to give him what he needed
he should have thought about that before
he married her um
but no i mean he makes good points to be
honest
because taking on a kid is a
big responsibility it is literally
the most important job you will ever
have in your life is raising
your kids um and taking on someone
else's responsibility
it's a lot to ask of a person and i can
totally understand why some people would
not want to sign up for that
so to be fair to her and to be fair to
kid
i had to leave that situation and look
honestly speaking
maybe if i was more blue pill and i
didn't care about myself
i would have stayed and still be stepped
out today but
i have to have to understand look my
life i want one life to live
so i want to be free to be successful
and i'll look today
we've built empire fresh and fit and now
i can say
i'm actually on the way to being super
successful the point is that like
for me personally back then that was
holding me back that whole dynamic of
having to like soccer games you know um
you know taking this difference in that
place having to spend money for trips
like
that's holding me back and it's it
sounds bad to say but like
i had to be selfish but now i'm at a
better point in life like
i can have my own kids i'm saying um but
back then it was a no and then to like
sorry to say this that's not my kid so
for me to give him
the world i personally can't do it
because
i'm looking at some other [ __ ] in his
face and i'm like bro
that's not my kid and then two in my
household
if i want to have discipline i can't
really do something because i can't hit
him
and then when i showed him he's like oh
he's not your son don't shout at him
how old was he he's like three oh
so nothing against her nothing as a kid
just that like me personally
i didn't know i was getting into uh i
did it for you know to be christian and
be
a good wholesome husband and actually
live with my wife
so i need to be married um so that's why
i actually did it i really didn't do all
the like love because like i cared about
her
but i didn't love her like you know i
don't yeah you needed your papers
no i was already a citizen okay yeah you
know funny
where is he from i don't even hear an
accent from barbados you got married for
papers no
my mom's from from new york so citizen
from birth his mom's a u.s citizen so
i've been i've been legal from
the jump i just knew personally i didn't
want to be in that situation anymore so
that's how i like this man because i
listened to him in the car
him solo tv 84 king riches uh richard
cooper
and they started making my mind think
you know what this is what i really want
as a man
you know i'm saying i'm young i to be
successful i don't know where i'm going
yet but i'm going somewhere
this is going to hold me back and it did
i let that go
it was it wasn't easy because obviously
i cared about the kid who cared about
about the girl
you know what i'm saying and you know up
to up until this day like i gave her the
car
hey you know i bought our car you keep
it
that was my my gift to you saying you
know what things didn't work out
i'm not gonna be a a-hole and just like
give you nothing so
here's that and we divorced she needed
to ask for nothing no money
no alimony nothing we divorced and that
was it and luckily i found a good girl
she cared about me and she did anything
for me after but you know
that's what would you ever consider
going back to her now that you're like
successful hell no but what what
hey man look i gave her a car she's a
good lifestyle i'm saying
i taught her how to but but her credit
okay so when i met her she had like a
credit score of like 300.
when i left there it was like damn it
was like no it was that low
yeah it was when it left it was 7 7 10.
so i gave her opportunity to like hey
grow your credit
now you can borrow money invest and all
so basically i helped her to a certain
extent
from the hood to a nice area so i gave
her some keys to life
that will bless her but me to go back
nah
yeah does that answer it kind of
where yeah that's it i mean i get it he
he was young
he didn't mention that um on the show so
23 that's very yeah i can give you like
the the logical reasoning why it's
well men don't want to raise another
guy's kid i think that's what it comes
down to
and i know a lot of girls that feel the
same way like there's a ton of girls
that i know that
like they'll run if they know that
someone has a kid
so we tell guys on a podcast all the
time uh not to date single moms or take
them seriously and the reason why
there's a
there's a bunch of reasons why yeah but
um if i'm gonna go
over i wrote down something hold on here
we go
number one so uh number one you have a
hundred percent responsibility with
almost zero authority
you know at the end of the day the kid
isn't yours biologically so you have
zero uh rights to that child if
something were to happen so if the woman
breaks up with you or leaves you
you've now built up rapport and love
with a child that isn't biologically
yours that you have
zero right to so i actually
i've heard about men um like there's a
guy that i know
that happened to him he literally raised
a kid for 10 plus years
and then the mom as soon as i broke up
nah
you can't see the kid so she can
leverage that child against you and just
leave and then it's not it's
the relationship breaking up is gonna
hurt you and then if she has one two
three four kids that you're caring for
that you're investing into
now you have no right to them so it
hurts three times four times as hard
right
and then also on top of that um
it's not in your best interest as a man
to invest all your resources and time
into children
that quite frankly aren't yours it's
it's it's why are you raising another
man's child when you can go ahead and
have your own children
you know it's just not it's it's not uh
how do i say this it's not it's not the
best it's not most conducive to your
personal success and it's not the best
use of your time you're better off just
finding a woman getting with her younger
having a child with her
and making sure that at least the kids
are yours because if the kids are yours
you at least have a fighting chance well
not even you have a fighting chance
you're still going to lose in family
court regardless you're probably not
going to even
get custody of your children yeah but at
least you'll have a sliver of right to
be able to get them and be able to see
them
so when the kids aren't biologically
yours you take a l
there's literally no upside to being a
step dad at all
there's there's none so we tell guys
the courts aren't designed for you to
win and when the kids aren't
biologically yours
the courts are 100 designed for you to
lose so
it's it's a it's there's zero upsides
being stepped at quite frankly
so there's no hope for me
how's your kid eight yeah i mean
the thing is this wait ten more years i
mean it's not even wait ten more years
it's
no guy that's high that's
any guy that's sensible that has higher
earning and higher status they're
probably not going to take you seriously
and i just that's got to be the
like your best bet yeah like now she's
dating a guy with kids
so you can find a guy with kids as well
that's to make it work yeah that's what
i've seen work
the best actually because my sister had
two kids with her first husband
and they got divorced and now and her
second husband had a kid
and then they had a kid together because
think about what it is right like you
said earlier or no [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that get back with the baby's
father man
he's married yeah yeah sometimes the guy
moves on like
her uh baby daddy moved on with another
girl so she could even she couldn't even
go back
but in your in your scenario find
somebody with kids because he
understands your struggle
because see i like like i said before i
don't really understand it i don't have
kids
on my own so it's kind of like i'm not
the best person to even be in that
scenario
but he might guide kids so or and you
can find a man you you can find one it's
just that you might not find the guy
that you want
like the thing is is like you know and
because i know
when a guy who makes a certain amount of
money 100 grand a year six feet tall
good looking whatever it may be
you can find a man to be a strong
stepfather there's nothing wrong with
being a stepfather
you know i'm just saying like on a
balance of probabilities it's not in
your best interest
but there are plenty of average men that
will be happy
to take you on as a wife and take on
your son and be a stepfather yeah we've
seen your booty so
you're good to go you can do it you know
what i'm saying it's just that yeah the
thing is is that
many women have very high standards man
and and quite frankly
the older you get you know and the more
children you have the less negotiating
power you have to get these types of men
and lock them down they might have sex
with you
i would agree because having a kid with
the wrong person
it will ruin your life i have never seen
more lives ruined than having a kid with
the wrong person casually not fun
they'll have fun
but they won't lock you down so um you
know i would say
maybe knock the standards down a bit and
i know
you might fight me on that but or uh
what what what do you got chris
or some cats and dogs or guy alone
yeah investing chewy diet guys i would
say there's not listen the average man
in the united states makes about 50
grand a year five foot eight
yeah there's nothing wrong with that
yeah i'm five ten
that well you're five ten yes no you're
not i am oh yeah
she's pretty slow just like oh my
goodness hold up
hold up you know dating is a tall female
that's such a struggle oh my god i'm six
foot i'm five eleven and a half
oh it's a struggle we'll have a high
conflicts yes
no okay okay uh i guess i guess okay oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah she does got you by like an
inch bro yeah she just got you by like
uh
turn around turn around
oh okay there you go i know some dudes
in the in this chat are gonna be oh i'll
be there
like six two okay then you're telling me
it was
you want a man that's what six foot
three yes and a hundred grand a year
i mean not really a hundred like maybe
eighty eighty okay
well you're you're looking for me in
miami you know how it is here's the
thing you're looking for a guy in like
the top five percent
right because oh so let's do the math
about 15
14 14 or so of men uh are six feet tall
yeah that's just especially in miami
it's like they're like and even
eight yeah so to find a man that's six
foot three you're already talking about
a two or three percent man now include
single now include single
ready to mingle he's ready to mingle
then let's add in is he attractive
enough
yeah right i could tell your picky on
looks then let's add in the fact he
needs to make 80 grand a year
yep uh you gotta settle you know what
when you stood up
i think you changed a child's mind
guys guys guys you know why i did that
this is so true guys will say oh i
wouldn't date
i wouldn't date this i wouldn't date
that dude and then a hot girl walks in
and they're like you know what
i swear to god full package because yeah
i'm telling you bro some [ __ ] will
yeah some guys will still do it for you
some guys will take you on i'm just
saying like
if you want a guy to commit to you take
you seriously and be ready to take you
on as a wife and
and take care of your son yeah you're
going to have to settle
starter sorry um you're going to have to
settle um
with a guy that may not be six foot
three and
you know attractive and making 80 grand
plus a year you know
i can't believe she wants six three at
five
ten i'm six foot i always say i'd go
down to five
ten so that's like shocking to me
that she needs like if she's five ten
she should date a guy that's five ten
or at least like five eleven like an
inch taller
we got our boy uh fortune vieira here
thank you again witness competition
anxiety for 13 years when land dancing
astronauts okay because even my mom
thinking about this she's dating or she
dating
married um to like what a lot of girls
want like the super rich
guy and she had a million like as many
kids as she wanted to have
um and
yeah if that was the requirements like
if she had this lady's requirements my
dad wouldn't have made it cause my dad's
five will love it
let's dance and watch the eyeballs turn
see you bros in miami
tomorrow cool all right man thank you
very much cool um
but yeah that's what i was saying i mean
just for answering my questions yeah
that's like a very from a very painful
and pragmatic side but there's plenty of
guys
yeah that would be happy to be
stepfathers like a lot yeah they don't
watch us they're like yeah i'll do it
you know oh you got a bunch of guys here
they're probably gonna send you a
look yeah that ass now so yeah
oh my gosh this is that was so
interesting
um no i definitely agree with them when
it comes to
i understand why you wouldn't want to
date someone with kids
that makes total sense to me and
i would never fault someone who doesn't
want to date someone with kids like how
can you be mad at someone who just
doesn't want to date you
but let me know what you guys think in
the comments don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring the
notification bell and i will talk to you
guys
next